[Musique]
la deuxième édition du relais pour la
vie s'est déroulée à bras panon
un événement organisé par la ligue
contre le cancer qui rassemble des
équipes de marcheurs et des coureurs qui
se relaient pendant 24 heures
sur la base du volontariat des agents
des départements nommé team cédé 9 7 4
étaient présents pour soutenir l'action
je suis agent de la collectivité
je suis citoyen et la collectivité
effectivement nous a
aussi dans un esprit de valeur
effectivement humaniste par rapport aux
problématiques qui nous entourent va
d'être solidaires et de participer en
fait à ce genre de manifestations
extrêmement important donc en tant
qu'agent la collectivité je participe
vraiment et puis en tant que citoyen je
suis également
dans le cadre de mes amis
ma famille concernée
très peu partout par ce fléau très
cancer donc une mobilisation que je
tout à fait
indispensable à la manifestation a pour
but de récolter des fonds afin d'aider
et d'accompagner les malades en
situation financière précaire
[Musique]